If you're scared
you're not going to take the chances that you need to take to realize
your dreams.
If you are making a decision based out of fear, you lose.
That step towards your fear is the step into bravery.
Rise and shine. It's #Entspresso time. What's up belief nation?
It's Evan, I believe in you and this channel is designed to be a part of your daily success routine.
So let's start your day off right together grab your coffee and sip on today's message. #Don't let fear stop you.
Over you Will Smith.
Also If you want to know what Will Smith and other successful entrepreneurs have to say about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series, where every day for the next
254 days I will send you a morning video for free to help you build your confidence,
the link to join is in the description below.
I was excited about
taking a shot, the fact that it was so strange, you know as an artist it was
Fun to get out on that
limb and hoping it doesn't break under your feet.
I look at the world through a lens of comedy.
My natural reaction is always no matter, when something happens and I can't even help it, it's why is that funny?
I've never seen myself as
particularly talented, where I excel is I'm willing to die in the process of acquiring skill.
My parents drove us
cross-country to, we were going to California for a family reunion. So we drove
to the Grand Canyon and
we got there and I like, I remember having a deeply meaningful
experience of how beautiful it was, but I was terrified to walk up to the edge
and
all my brothers and sisters and my whole family walked up to the edge and I stayed back.
Scared to take in beauty
If you're scared,
you're not going to take the chances that you need to take
to realize your dreams,
and that was the thing for me.
I don't mind being scared but,
I'm still gonna do it.
The reason why you are stuck is because you are afraid of taking
action and you've convinced yourself that there is a logical reason for you to stay in mediocrity.
Anytime you want to go off and do something
and you hesitate and the next words out of your mouth are "I'm afraid of _____"
filling the blank, then you have to stop and
recognize that you have to go and do that thing.
Making decisions based out of fear is your cancer
it is the single biggest thing that is crippling your success
and until you fix it, you will talk yourself down from your big ideas for life.
I had a young entrepreneur come on my morning show and asked me if he should go and quit his university
take a year off to go work for his mentor in a different city.
So I asked him, well what's on his mind? And the first thing he said was, "well I'm afraid"
'Ding ding ding ding ding ding' as soon as you say that
lights need to be going off in your head, if your answer is ever
"well, I'm afraid". His answer was,
well I'm afraid that if I leave I
may not be able to get back in,
that it's gonna be hard for me to come back and join the program if that year doesn't work out.
That is the wrong filter through which to make a decision.
If you are making a decision based out of fear you lose, because he'll end up not going to take that job
which he really want to take, not going to work for that mentor who he really wants to work for because he's afraid.
And then when he graduates in two years
that opportunity like a little closed,
it won't be there anymore
and ultimately he loses.
He took the safe sure bet instead of the one that he actually wanted to take
and he hates his life for now.
You need to understand that there is a window on the opportunities of your ideas.
There is a window of opportunity that is not gonna stay open forever.
That if you have something in your head a dream, a goal, a vision,
something you want to act on, that will not be around forever.
Not just you won't be around forever, but that opportunity won't be around forever
This is a moment in time that you have right now. And if you don't push all in you will regret it,
and if the reason for you not push it all in is because you're afraid of something,
you are setting yourself up for failure and unhappiness for life.
So how do you fix it? How do you prevent yourself from screwing yourself over?
I have a three-step process that I called
"The bold identity" and here's what it looks like:
Number one.
Identify it.
I want to do this thing.
If I did this thing
I would be super excited, if you don't have anything excited
or something makes you nervous in your schedule, you hate your life.
And so what is the big thing that you dream of that you want to do? Step number one.
Number two, super important,
What would the boldest version of you do?
You have a dream.
What would the boldest, most fearless version of you be doing and write that down on your piece of paper.
Let go of any fears, let go of any inhibitions, let go of all the reasons why it's not gonna work.
What would the boldest version of you do?
And step number three
Now this process of the bold identity is not very complicated.
But it's difficult to do, it's hard to do because it requires you to actually be bold.
But here's the thing, if you could wear that hat
just for a minute, if you wear that hat of boldness you take on the bold identity,
and you say what would the most bold version of myself do in this situation?
That is actually the right thing for you.
The decisions that you make when you are feeling bold and
unstoppable are actually the things that you should be doing.
Those brief moments of courage that you have and you decide something that is
actually the best thing for you and then your brain will start talking down from it,
your brain will start thinking about all the reasons why you should not go of and do that thing.
And so that's why the third step of taking immediate action is so important
because just because you've identified
what the thing is that you want to do and then you ask yourself,
What would the boldest version of yourself do when you get all pumped up if you wait until tomorrow?
It's not gonna happen. You need to take immediate action.
Now, I've got a really special bonus clip for you but before that
question of the day, I want to know what would the boldest version of you be doing right now?
Let me know put in the comments below.
You've lived a life dominated by doubt and fear. How do you step into bravery?
Step.
That's how you step into bravery, step, take the step.
Step aggressively towards your fear,
and that, that step towards your fear is the step into bravery.
Because we're scared of what we don't know
and
there's only one way,
to learn and to know and that is to confront that fear.
You have to step you have to go and this simple action,
this simple attitude,
it answers so many questions
so many questions.
How do you get to the gym every day?
You step, you go.
How do you how do you change your diet?
You step,
you go.
How do you overcome fear of failure or fear of success or fear of fear itself?
You step.
And how do you face the fear of the unknown? You step.
Don't wait anymore, don't think anymore don't plan anymore. Don't contemplate anymore.
Don't make any more excuses or justifications.
Don't rationalize anything else. No.
No, and no.
Instead,
be aggressive, take action now and what is the first action that you need to take?
What's the first step you need to take?
The first step you need to take is just that
step.
Maybe you keep the one word secret to happiness,
one word it's all you need to be happy.
The most important word ever.
If you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that sums your apple. That would be like a little beacon.
If you want more Will Smith check out the top 50 rules video I made on him. I think you'll enjoy it.
The link is right there next to me continue to believe and I'll see you there.
You've got to take a shot. You have to live at the edge of your capabilities,
you got to live where you're almost certain you're gonna fail.